now you're ready to turn over your page
turn over your page and I'll appreciate
the beauty of the metric system there
wheezing now you guys can help me with
this because you already know at least
2/3 of the page we're gonna form as the
last third okay so here's what you got
let's remember that essentially speaking
in the metric system even though you can
go you can go further into smaller units
or if you want even if further into okay
we essentially have four main units okay
um they're the kilometer the mean option
the centimeter and the millimeter okay
now what I'm going to do is in one
diagram I'm gonna progressively do all
three diagrams that you've got in front
of you okay so in terms of conversions
if you have another color get that one
out so that it's um gonna be clear on
your diagram okay when you move from say
one kilometer right how many meters are
there in a kilometer it's up 1,000 which
is why we use through the prepping kilo
it means a thousand right same with a
kilogram or a kiloliter
right so to get for one to a thousand we
multiply by a thousand right
this unit is really big and this one's
much smaller so if they're both
equivalent then the numbers over here
I've got a much bigger
oh I'm so glad you asked that
okay because this is kind of a big point
and why it's confusing right let's go to
a physical example if I say two
kilometers right that is equal to 2,000
meters okay it's not equal to one mm mm
Edith okay and the reason why is this
unit is really big so even when you have
a small number of them even because
they're so large you get a large number
of a smaller unit so that's why it is
multiplication and in fact it's
multiplication all the way going from
beep units to small units okay
can we finish it and then discuss better
that again so now when we go from meters
to centimeters of course it's not
multiplied by thousand its multiplied by
a hundred right it's all in terms of
tens right and then the last one wickiup
how many millimeters in acetaminophen
pretend excellent you can see this
beautiful step down and it makes sense
okay and obviously if we want to go in
the opposite direction we would divide
by ten or divide by a hundred or divided
by a thousand okay fantastic now what we
took these units right the wonderful
thing about this is that it moves
straight up to area these are all legs
it restricted area so easily right
instead of having a kilometer you just
have a square kilometer right which is
why on your diagram your second row you
have squares there right and you've got
square meters so I can write me to swear
you've got square centimeters and square
millimeters but because everything is
squared all the units are square when
you convert between them you also square
that's right and you should have had
this diagram when you were talking about
converting area right so for example if
I went from square kilometers to square
meters yeah yep a cosmic and then with
the next one yes correct
so that's why I've given you I've given
you more but I don't have that space so
you can see area in terms of area if
these units are square then when I
convert I multiplied by whatever squared
whatever squared or divided divided by
10 squared divided by a hundred squared
divided by a thousand square okay so now
we're up to where we were yesterday
looking at volume right so volume is not
in two dimensions is it it's in three
which is why on your next throw down you
have a whole bunch of cute right so here
is a cubic kilometer so this is not
going to be able to anymore I'm you
might as you can see it's a three
right I've just gotta just might as I go
so I've got a three here and that's why
it's cubed a three here and there's my
cube and even cubic millimeters which
are tiny tiny little things okay now
just like we said before because the
units are cute that means our conversion
process will also be cute okay so if you
were to go from cubic kilometers to
cubic meters you'd multiply by a
thousand cubed which is a really big
number right depending on what country
you're in it's either a thousand million
or a billion but I want to get into that
Club discussion I mean multiplying by
about 100 cubed or even look at this
right one cubic centimeter okay just
like we drew in our books right one
cubic centimeter is how many cubic
millimeters one cubic centimeter it's
gonna be 10 times 10 times 10 that's a
thousand ten times on it's a thousand
cubic millimeters because key
millimeters are so tiny right and in the
same way you would divide by 10 cubed or
divided by 100 cubed or a thousand cubed
if you were doing that conversions the
other way